si dice che diventare genitori sia
l'emozione più grande è che un essere
umano possa mai provare a creare un
altro essere umano e nutrirlo difetto 1
scienza gentilezza è una di quelle cose
che una fetta di persone non vede l'ora
di poter provare nella propria vita si
sono state chiedendo e l'altra fitta di
persone
beh se vogliamo proprio essere precisi
l'altra fetta si divide a sua volta in
un altre tre categorie a chi non vuole e
non può e chi proprio non avrebbe mai
dovuto che mi sono chiesto ma perché non
focalizzarci proprio su quest'ultima
fetta perché non celebrare la festa del
papa ricordando tutti quelli che sono
stati i peggiori in assoluto padri della
storia del cinema del folklore e della
mitologia perché non far sentire la
figura tanto tanto attaccata del padre
finalmente completa nel momento in cui
viene paragonato con qualcosa di
veramente orribile ecco perché ho deciso
di presentarvi una carrellata di patrick
è il giorno del concepimento dei figli
avrebbero non so fatto meglio ad andare
a giocare a biliardo in un'isola
sperduta in atlantico semplicemente
farsi una bella p iniziamo con il primo
padre il padre degli dei
zeus non essere pazzesco potentissimo
che se trombato mezza ten e le donne in
grecia scappavano perché conoscendo di
casacca arrivava zeus che l'ing rami da
la poi rosica vale trasformate in piante
invento in foglie in animali e anche
quando poi è diventato un personaggio
carino della disney il padre di hercules
e comunque il risultato un emerito
imbecille una persona che lasciava una
culla incustodita sapendo che aveva
mezzo olimpo contro perché si baseranno
testa licata lasciate in costruita in
modo che potessero prendergli il figlio
e renderlo mortale tra parentesi non
riuscendoci perché i nemici di zeus più
imbecilli diesel se stesso ea quel punto
mandarli in un posto lontano da lui e
zeus che nel frattempo forse sera
trombato pure la madre mortale di
hercules improvvisamente non si fa vivo
finché questo qui a cazzo non capita all
interno del suo tempio bravo quando ti
di conoscere un dio è come se ti
dicessero su un imbecille cioè trova la
figlia ogni angolo e non riesce a
trovare hercules finché non diventa più
adulto pisa perché era diventato mortale
ha quindi razza mandiamo muoviamoci in
un'altra epoca in un'epoca chino ambigua
tra il medioevo è una specie di universo
parallelo
della marvel all'interno della quale sta
nisba rate un fratello di un re
avvinazzato che c'è un peccato così
l'altro fratello un omosessuale rampante
forse stannis baratheon bagagli è
l'unico che non ha una tendenza che una
società bigotta può criticare la cosa
peggiore stannis baratheon e un picotto
tanto bigotto che nel momento in cui a
un certo punto arriva una donna vestita
di rosso a dirgli lo senti il profumo
della mia vagina
sai che cosa vorresti fare convertiti in
lui che cosa fa figli con il sai che ti
dico per vincere questa guerra brucerò
mia figlia al rogo altro genitori di
merda sempre lettori queste sessioni
verso i timing laniece ha tre figli due
gemelli in the il più piccolino il
problema è che questo qui i podi al
figlio più piccolo in primis perché
nascendo ha ucciso sua moglie nella
pancia di questa donna aveva un fucile
molto probabilmente colpa sua ovviamente
allo stesso tempo perché affetto da
sindrome di nanismo è quindi capisci
nano killer
spostiamoci piano adesso in un altro
mondo in un posto meraviglioso coag
forse all'interno del quale vive peter
griffin amato da tutti quanti fa
sorridere far ridere ma in realtà se
analizziamo quello che fa non sono un
padre di merda non è una persona di
merda peter è un alcolizzato che ha
ucciso la moglie del suo migliore amico
è l'unica volta in cui stato lasciato
solo con suo figlio l'ha ucciso peter
junior e per consumarsi cosa fallo
inserendo un cane un cane che si vuole
[ __ ] sua moglie brian peter fai
schifo ma continuano sempre con questa
idea di padri che vengono percepiti in
maniera pazzesca ma che in realtà sono
delle mere saliamo su una nuvoletta
d'oro che andiamo a incontrare son goku
amato da tutti quanti ragazzi nativo del
pianeta vegeta un uomo un padre che ha
passato più tempo col principe dei
saiyan piuttosto che con la sua prole ha
passato più tempo a combattere mostri
che a dare una carezza a suo figlio con
ogni volta in questo poi apprezzato da
tutti quanti perché abbiamo detto cavolo
ci tiene tanto suo figlio è stato quando
l'ha mandato contro sel a rischiare
quasi di crepare per sbloccare il suo
potenziale di rendete conto ma ha senso
questa cosa
parecchie volte quindi purtroppo non
tutte le monete di riserva bravo curdi
era il cazzo è un genitore che ha
chiamato suo figlio di riso vasto e poi
capiremo quello che chiama suo figlio
falco pasto è l'unica casa non riesce a
fare un tuo figlio e sederti con lui per
un pasto
lo fa nel libro giusto per mangiare chi
sei tu non lo sai un padre e due figli
al mondo porterà agli assistenti sociali
perché spostiamoci adesso molto molto
lontano all'interno di un regno
governato da re harold koh re harold era
l'occhio repa picchio qualcuno direbbe
il padre di fiona cos'è che fa quando
sua figlia viene maledetta e quindi si
ritrova improvvisamente a trasformarsi
in un orco la rinchiude in un castello
circondata da un drago all'interno del
quale fondamentalmente passa le giornate
a infilarsi qualsiasi cosa trovi
all'interno di quel posto all'interno
del q perché solo questo e riesco a
immaginare possa aver fatto c'è una
finale adesso per gestire frank schleck
senza problemi detto ciò non solo il re
harold fa modi shanin dalla figlia la
mette in una situazione pericolosa lo
permette farà finire dalle mani di un
drago a quelle di un orco e non basta
ragazzi morire in maniera estremamente
simpatica per essere perdonate non basta
cioè molto simpatica quella scena ma
rimane sempre un uomo di merda e anzi
avrei dovuto soffrire molto di più su
quel letto di morte per quanto mi
riguarda ma rimaniamo molto lontano
solamente che cambiamo completamente
traiettorie finiamo in una galassia una
grazia molto molto lontano
darth vader il padre di merda una
persona che manco mostra la sua faccia
perché altrimenti ci sputeremo sopra
partorisce due gemelli con lui li ha
partoriti cui capisci la moglie morente
parte dei giovani di lui qualcosa fatti
è in bocca al lupo ragazzi due gemelli
che si innamorano tra di loro cioè non
dice un cazzo a nessuno dei due
l'unico momento nel quale dice a
insegniamo le ducati tagli alla mano al
figlio
sono combattere rapisce lei alla fine
capito dice scusa scusa si scusa mi di
come se ogni volta i miei genitori
avessero rimosso pezzi del mio corpo io
sarei una testa il capo di art attack
katech bader non è che poi basta che si
pente rimani un uomo di merda e poi alla
fine darth vader cosa fa con sbagliato e
fa fuori palpatina che chiaramente
molestatore uno che si chiama palpati
imbecille fa un po la storia di tito
secondo me ce l'avete vedono poi sono i
metodi non è padre perché mai e l'hanno
data picone 40 anni vergine sempre
capito o lo immagino la stanza di piton
con tutti quanti i poster della povera
lì lì attaccati alle pareti senza chiodi
vogliamo parlare di un altro padre
terribile un egoista che non riesce a
comprendere propri limiti geppetto dopo
che muore la moglie dopo capito che ha
vissuto la sua vita
la cosa fa dice io voglio un figlio e
con una sega crea un burattino va a
dormire e quell'altra imbecille della
fata turchina arrivo è stato io che un
solo neurone e potevo fare questa magia
per una vita intera trasformerà o questo
arbusto in un bambino un bambino che di
per sé una testa di cazzo ok però
chiaramente i comportamenti di un essere
che ha ricevuto un'educazione di merda
soffre perché non è un bambino vero una
condizione nella quale tu l'hai nesso
geppetto e poi se ti lamenti che la
testa di legno cosa hai fatto con legno
abbastanza scegli un altro materiale ci
pensavi due volte e vissero felici e
contenti dugento vi è schiodato
pinocchio si ritrova un orfano non è una
bella storia era molto meglio il finale
di collodi fine li può il pubblico il
nome non può morire pinocchio meglio ho
già detto non può reggere quel bambino
era una storia di crescita per geppetto
vecchio hai fatto tu errori quello che
doveva essere un romanzo di formazione
per gli adulti arrivate una certa non
potete avere tutto geppetto costruisciti
una bella avanti legno e in groppa di la
fata turchina non lo so fare qualcosa ma
non andare in giro cerca di essere un
padre se pessimo qualche nome eccetto e
lo chiama pinocchio finisco qui l'elenco
di padri di merda perché mi sto
alterando anzi fatemi sapere qua sotto
nei commenti chi sono altri padri
orribili secondo voi perchè mi voglio
leggere uno
con le motivazioni e nel frattempo s'è
vista piaciuta questo video mettete un
po di censo iscritte o questo canale
attivate la campagna delle notifiche
attualmente non voglio lasciarvi con
questa nota amara giorno fa stare papa
bisogna anche se come parlare per par
condicio tutti quelli che sono stati i
padri migliori della storia secondo me è
qui vi chiedo di farmi sapere quali sono
stati secondo voi è padre migliori della
storia
partiamo col primo padre secondo me
modello che manco era il padre biologico
di hercules il becchino che aveva più le
nostre seta di geppetto che s'è fatto il
vero mazzo ha preso questo neonato l'ha
fatto crescere nonostante avesse una
forza erculea questo qui distruggerà
tutto quanto e lui li pagava per quel
figlio e poi al cus che cosa fa quel
piglio di merda nell'olimpo facendo
mentre diciamo tutto suo padre alcune
rimane sulla terra vedete la buona
educazione ecco perché più importante
che ti fa crescere piuttosto di kitty
dalla nascita cartone veramente
encomiabile l'olimpo e dall'altra parte
vogliamo parlare sennò di marlin che fa
di tutto per ritrovare il suo piccolo
nemo un pesciolino ragazzi perso
nell'oceano pacifico atlantico il grande
blu che ha paura lui di andare alla
ricerca di un granello di sabbia
all'interno di una spiaggia no lui si
rimbocca le pinne e bar a fini che cosa
che fa lui salva suo figlio nemo
combattendo contro squali meduse
pescecani balene umani motoscafi
qualsiasi cosa
marlin un cercatore ce l'ha fatta
vogliamo parlare forse risultano un
padre che non ha un nome quindi già
meraviglioso un padre che è una nuvola
l'unico padre pio vorrei toccare e
sentire i suoi pantaloni il suo cappello
che consistenza anno sotto le mani con
padre un monarca che si fa chiamare
sultano ma che acconsente comunque nella
sua umiltà che la figlia sposi uno
straccione
e non è un motivo per cui adesso non lo
fa perché troppo buono è perché si
circonda di persone che in realtà basta
non è fargli il lavaggio del cervello
vi rendete conto di che persona squisita
e seguirà il morso
sultano sa tipo di marshmallow vogliamo
parlare di invasa mufasa che muore per
aiutare quell'imbecille di simba viene
travolto per salvare chi quel perfetto
beota l'inizio e qualcuno di voi
potrebbe pensare che per essere un buon
padre tu debba per forza rischiare la
morte o morire assolutamente non
parliamo di un padre secondo me modello
uno dei migliori aragog un enorme ragno
ceco quindi anche in difficoltà che
davanti all'occasione non esita a
cercare di far uccidere due minorenni
harry e ron ai suoi figli pur di
sfamarli pur di portare un pasto caldo
alla propria famiglia quale padre
commettere un omicidio simile per i
propri figli solo aragon para look è
cieco ma ci vede lontano quando si
tratta del bene della propria famiglia
ho i brividi altro padre modello
tecnicamente non è proprio un padre ma
lo inserisco all'interno di quella
categoria che essere che dona la vita a
qualcun'altro key in fi sager di alien
quello che esce dalle uova che cosa fa
questo essere un essere squisito si
avvinghia la faccia di uno lo tiene in
vita perché misericordioso il frattempo
innesta l'embrione di alien lui protegge
in tutti i modi fa qualsiasi cosa come
una farfalla dire praticamente
pochissimo tutto per far sfondare a quel
piccolo do il 100 di figliolino lo
sterno dell'ospite e questo quindi che
cos'è che fa la fine di tutto quanto non
è che poi gioca a pallone con alien
capito gli arrivano per la festa del
papà i bigliettini no
muore si sacrifica per donare la vita
tecnicamente non è un padre sei forse ma
chi siamo noi per giudicare genitore 1 i
genitori due delle razze aliene o billa
di kill bill
la squisitezza di un uomo nonostante mi
sei un assassino forse uno spacciatore
molto probabilmente abbia le teste di
tutte le sue vittime e potrebbero
foderare completamente tutta l'aria di
un campo da calcio noi cosa che fa
proteggere sua figlia da chi da sua
madre e da se stesso
magari non è il marito migliore perché
ci sta un marito non spara un colpo di
pistola ha una moglie certo alzo le mani
non è il datore di lavoro migliore ok ma
un padre squisito nei confronti della
piccola b b le prepara dei toast sensi
la crosta a voi questo padre mi
preparava i toast senza la crosta a me
ma almeno una volta nella mia vita
altro eccellente adre l'anatra di kung
fu panda ping genitore tipo insegna a
suo figlio l'importanza del lavoro suo
figlio torna a casa penso di non avere
nessun talento pensati essere una frode
capito cosa fa lo abbraccia mentre
abbraccia e li mette un grembiule come
per dirgli qui se a casa ma ricordati le
cose non ti vengono date si deve
rimboccare le maniche e soprattutto
ricordati che l'ingrediente segreto con
esiste e gli svolta tutto quanto
l'ingrediente segreto sei tu ma quale
padre anatra direbbe una cosa così al
proprio figlio panda per quanto mi
riguarda un esempio di umanità che viene
da un animale commovente e nel momento
in cui poi in pose neri va via una
grigia torni da me solamente quando stai
male no lui gli dice in un tacito
accordo quando tornerà gameti ci sarà
sempre da invola perché una cosa è
dedicato da me le mie ali
mamma mia poi chiudere col brivido e
alla fine di questo video vorrei parlare
un secondo di mio padre
raramente ho parlato di mio padre forse
mai innanzitutto auguri proprio davanti
alla domanda in quale categoria si
posiziona tuo papà nella prima o nella
seconda la mia risposta e in nessuna
delle due perché mio padre è un uomo non
è una storia non è una leggenda non è un
mito e come tutte quante le persone
incarna poli che a volte possono essere
contrastanti ma come me come te che ora
sta guardando questo video ora sarò
sincero come arrivando nel proprio stato
idilliaco in passato il rapporto perché
il tempo insegna sicuramente alle
persone diventare genitori ma il tempo
dovrebbe insegnare anche alle persone a
essere figli e rapporto fra genitori e
figli è un rapporto che col tempo
incomincia a variare c'è un momento nel
quale indubbiamente i genitori sono
fondamentali e un momento nel quale
veramente ci danno un imprinting a
enorme utilissimo essenziale per la
nostra vita ma arriva un secondo momento
dei quali figli non l'occasione di poter
permettere ai genitori di crescere ecco
perché i figli sono una grande ricchezza
perché nel momento in cui anche i
genitori imparano a permettere figli di
mettere in pratica quello che loro
hanno insegnato automaticamente allora
torna qualcosa di meraviglioso indietro
e devo dire che col tempo il rapporto
tra me e mio padre ha subito una svolta
totale del quale sono estremamente
contento che continua ad evolversi e
niente spero che qualora voi abbiate
avuto o abbiate dei problemi con la
vostra famiglia problemi che magari
possono essere risolti come nel mio caso
almeno che vostro padre non sia zeus
io credo che spesso la nostra analisi
nei confronti dei nostri genitori a
volte è un po dura per lo meno la mia
sicuramente lo è stata perché a volte è
molto più semplice più comodo
nascondersi dietro l'incomunicabilità
che fare quel passato che ci permette di
crescere
vi mando un bacio auguri a tutti quanti
papà del mondo dell'universo tranne a
zeus un bacio ci vediamo domenica un
nuovo video su questo canale ciao